welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and even though we
saw jennifer walters hired as glk and
h's new hulk attorney based on her
superhuman abilities i decided to build
a little case of my own just how keen of
a legal mind is she hulk according to
the court of comic lore could we see the
mcu adapt some of her comic cases move
over nelson and murdock today i'm going
to break down some of she-hulk's wildest
cases and maybe even prove to you why
jennifer walters is a badass regardless
of hulk status now jennifer walter she
hulk has been lawyering since the 80s so
her comic persona has tried a lot of
cases but one of my favorite things
about the mid-2000s she-hulk comics is
that they actually made comic book
issues legitimate legal sources for many
of jen's defenses in several instances
she literally has the ability to go to
the basement pull a few long boxes and
utilize any and every marvel comic book
as factual evidence in 2004 she-hulk vol
1 were introduced to the goodman
lieber-kurtzberg and holloway law firm
for the first time which is where jen
gains comic book knowledge as a legal
defense though because she-hulk attorney
law is drawing so much from her
mid-aughts run i thought it would be fun
to do the same i'm gonna take a cue from
she-hulk and draw my evidence from her
comic history in my defenses of her
legal career just like in the tv series
jen's first case in 2004 she-hulk vol 1
is actually declared a mistrial in the
case of new york versus paxton mr
paxton's warehouse full of antarctic
vibranium collapsed due to improper
storage of its materials jen manages to
successfully argue that because
vibranium breaks down the molecular
cohesion of all metals it would also
affect the iron in folks's blood causing
life-threatening conditions like cancer
diabetes heart disease and liver disease
but although it's very clear that paxton
should absolutely pay reparations for
the harm he's caused the case is
declared a mistrial because she hulk and
the avengers have recently saved earth
once again and the court decides that
the jury cannot be impartial luckily
things turn around for her next case
danger man vs roxanne corporation after
falling into a vat of heart atomic
waters dan germain transformed into
danger man a powerful radioactive super
beam while roxanne argues that there's
no way that anyone could consider
becoming a superpowered individual a
negative jen defends dan claiming that
his initial identity died the day he
became danger man he and his family are
awarded an 85 million dollar settlement
as compensation for loss of life and
while i can't say for sure that we'll
see this exact case featuring danger man
pop up in the series there is absolutely
a non-zero chance that we'll eventually
see she-hulk take on the roxon corp in
the mcu roxanne has caused a lot of
major global safety issues namely the
company's massive oil spills revealed in
iron man 3. if series such as agent
carter and cloak and dagger are ever
confirmed as mcu-616 cannon their list
of crimes grows chiefly the creation and
harboring of atomic weapons of mass
destruction thanks to loki season one we
know that roxanne isn't going away
anytime soon so i predict that future
she-hulk episodes will eventually
feature jen being a pain in roxanne's
corporate ass i stare at screens all day
and that can be tough on my eyes it used
to be the case that i'd help my eyes out
by wearing a pair of blue blocks blue
light glasses but blue box has become
bond charge thankfully the glasses have
stayed the same got my little glasses in
my little case and now i'm gonna put
them on my little face
bond charges a couple of different
glasses depending on what you need my
go-to are the computer glasses they help
reduce sore eyes headaches watery eyes
and fatigue if i'm staring at a computer
all day or i'm in a room with
fluorescent lights these glasses are my
first line of defense bond charges
glasses are backed by science and tested
to make sure they work which is not the
case with other light blocking glasses
on the market if you've got a
prescription you can get these with a
prescription if you don't you can get
them without a prescription just need a
pair of light blocking reading glasses
bond charge can handle that too bond
charge ships worldwide and have other
great products like low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and 100 light
blocking sleep masks go to
bondcharge.com new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
percent that's v-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e
dot com slash new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
some of my favorite she-hulk cases from
the comics are the ones involving
testimonies from the dead not only did
she win the case of briggs vs nelson in
which the ghost of the murder victim
briggs testified in open court against
his alleged killer he was also
responsible for going toe-to-toe with
matt murdock in the case of folger vs
rogers the latter is one of she-hulk's
coolest cases in my opinion because we
get to see jen duke it out with matt in
the courtroom for the very first time
steve rogers is accused of being
responsible for the death of sam folgers
before he became captain america by
sam's brother harold the interesting
part harold is dead and his testimony
comes from a dying declaration he made
prior to kicking the bucket swearing to
avenge his brother in court from beyond
the grave although matt puts up a solid
argument as the prosecutor steve and jen
are able to prove cap's innocence cap
later reveals that most of the evidence
given to matt was falsified by his
nemesis dr faustus but he needed the
best lawyers on both sides to duke it
out and to prove to the public that he
wasn't getting biased treatment with a
confirmed daredevil appearance in
she-hulk soon i'm sincerely hoping that
they get to spar in the court of law
like in this comic run jen has also
represented more soups and defamation
lawsuits than i can possibly fit into
one video but each of these cases shed
an important light on the grey area of
herodome and she doesn't always win for
example in the case of spider-man vs the
daily bugle both spidey and j jonah
jameson have solid arguments for why
they continue to torment each other with
falsified news stories ultimately the
two newsies decide to settle out of
court realizing that neither will win
the case another technical loss for gen
speaking of defamation cases we can't
skip over the time that the new warriors
get doxed by a website called escape
enterprises in this r key hulk uses her
powerful connections to find the jerk
responsible for outing this set of
heroes the problem the new warriors are
universally hated for their inability to
prevent the villain nitro from causing
an explosion that killed thousands the
public opinion is not on their side
ultimately jen is able to hunt down the
doxer and put a stop to it before any
additional new warriors are killed
securing another win for she-hulk
because of the fact that spider-man no
way home focused so heavily on the
public's opinion of peter parker after
the death of mysterio i think we're
gonna see many more mcu defamation suits
in the future true we didn't get to see
a play-by-play of matt murdock's defense
of peter's actions but now that we have
an entire lawyer series and both
characters are officially working in the
mcu i'm certain that we'll see more of
these types of lawsuits against heroes
in the future finally we gotta talk
about two of jen's most important
victories even though they technically
took place outside of the american
justice system i believe that these two
events prove beyond a shadow of a doubt
that jen walters is a banging attorney
and not to be [ __ ] with first up
there's her win against the tva who
brought her to their headquarters to
erase her from existence why well jen
might have kinda sorta broke the most
cardinal rule of time travel actually
the second most cardinal rule of time
travel the first cardinal rule of time
travel is do not go back in time and put
yourself in a situation where your mom
will try to bang you but the second rule
is definitely that you cannot meddle
with time in order to prevent your
friend's death [ __ ] like that is
guaranteed to cause a rift in space and
time but jennifer decides to warn
hawkeye of his impending doom when his
living past self is brought in to
testify in the present day he's brought
before the tva for her crimes against
time facing permanent expulsion from
reality this time it isn't jen that
saves herself with a brilliant defense
what keeps her alive is the fact that so
many reputable heroes come forward to
vouch for her character innumerable
evidence is given that jennifer walter's
contributions to the multiverse as a
lawyer and a super-powered individual
are too important to delete forever and
the tva reluctantly allows her to live
but these heroes weren't wrong she-hulk
really is far too important to lose
especially after winning the most
important case of all 616 versus the
living tribunal in she-hulk volume 2
number 20 it's revealed that jen was
taken off the world by the living
tribunal and forced to make a case to
save the entirety of the comic's 616
timeline apparently the lt was looking
to replace 616 with the newer more
stylish ultimate universe aka the cosmic
equivalent of a hot trophy wife they
wanted to erase that entire corner of
the multiverse but jen managed to
convince them that 616 is charming not
just in spite of but because of its
convoluted history obviously this was an
editorial in joke about marvel comics
and their reboot attempts with the
ultimate universe but it's canon den
really did save the entirety of 616
through her lawyer skills i don't know
about you but this comic story reminds
me a lot of the ending of eternals when
cersei fastos and kingo are captured by
erysham who informs them that he'll be
using their memories to judge humanity
in the same way that their experiences
will have to convince aeroshem to spare
earth j-hulk was similarly forced to
argue for her world's salvation this
might be a little bit of a rogue theory
but what if shield gets involved helping
these three eternals save the mcu from
heirsham's judgment in future movies i
know i know the eternals have the
situation covered but it would be so fun
to see jennifer walter's space attorney
duking it out alongside cersei with the
big red lego in the sky i might be wrong
but be a girl can dream you gotta admit
tying in the comics 616 universe with
the judgment of the mcu would be a
pretty fun way to showcase that despite
the occasional misstep or mistrial
jennifer walters might just be the most
talented lawyer in the multiverse how
could she not be she single-handedly
uncovered the truth about captain
america's sex life and we as a society
can never repay her for that these are
merely but a delicate sprinkling of the
many court cases from the comics that
prove she held is in fact a very good
attorney i want to hear some of your
favorite verdicts in the comments i'm
sure i ran out of time to list all of
her best cases so hit me up below and
let me know which cases you think might
pop up in future she-hulk episodes or
films follow me on instagram and twitter
whitneypuppy follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you